i i'll just say this i want to stress
that i think aoc um
and to a certain degree trump but trump
certainly has a better understanding of
how
economics and trade functions but this
this element of
press mogul politicians is a problem for
us right
i think aoc is a bigger problem because
she has no experience and no
understanding
and she does has like there's a lot of
things trump has done whether you like
it or don't like it he's done
a lot of things the economy was really
really great aoc has done
nothing she's renamed like i think
couple post offices and other than that
it's been nothing
it's been puff pieces and fluff and and
gestures that's made her famous now
nine point something million followers
on twitter for what
and they re-elect to her right and i
think even worse
you will get generations more of aoc's
right nobody i don't think anyone in
their right mind would want to be trump
right now so whatever else you think of
the guy
i don't think is his nobody's situation
and his position is enviable
uh and certainly he's probably not
living the sort of carefree and easy
life he probably led 10 or 15 years ago
but what you're going to end up i think
what you're going to see and
unfortunately i think you're going to
start seeing it on the right too
no different than on the left is you're
going to see a whole bunch of people who
are probably in their teens and 20s now
who want to be aoc the next cycle or the
cycle after that or cycles down the road
and so you're going to end up with
a whole bunch of new a new crop of
politicians who want nothing other than
the star power and right now the way the
incentives are aligned
they're gonna get the followers they're
gonna get the money they're gonna write
books they're gonna sell out they're
gonna
they're gonna be on all the podcasts and
the tv shows and everything else and so
all of their incentives will be met
and the only person who's getting the
the short end on that deal is the
american people who elected all of these
people to lead them
now all of that operates under the
assumption that from where we are now
there's no dramatic and immediate
escalations
particularly following november 3rd so
assuming that what we see we get
increments of
i agree with you we'll end up with a
bunch a bunch more
social media influencer types who don't
really do anything other than like yo
look at my selfie i'm on instagram vote
for me and then people do
because they are on twitter yeah they're
gonna do it
but uh i think social media is driving a
hyper polarization which is gonna result
in
serious unrest and strife there was a
story that i talked about earlier today
the nypd has been training every day
for election day unrest so everybody's
kind of expecting this to reach some
kind of boiling point
so i guess you know in that regard i
wonder what your thoughts are yeah
you know i i go back and forth with a
few buddies of mine so most of my
friends are
are pretty left-leaning and i think one
of the things that we always come back
to is
how does the fever break right like
right now i think we can all agree
whether chicken head cut off or whatever
metaphor you want to use
we're at a point where it's not tenable
and it there doesn't seem to be to be a
good
easy way to back down from the sort of
abyss that we're staring into
and have us come to a more peaceful
understanding of our differences and the
way we all work and and what have you
so i do worry like i think where i where
i net out to and where i always fall out
to in these conversations is
i'm worried that there probably will be
violence before it gets better it will
continue to get worse before it gets
better
and at some point there's going to be
nothing but violence and i hope that
that i hope that i'm wrong right i sound
a little bit
and i get that i sound a little bit like
an extremist similar off my rocker when
i say that i think that's gonna be the
case but
i guess i just don't know how else we
continue to move forward at the pace
we're at
at the increasing kind of it's like the
music keeps getting faster and faster
and there's no one there to shut off the
music i think so what happens when we're
all running into each other ahead long
i think people are scared to admit that
there's going to be violence yeah
it's it's if people are scared to say it
because of their optimism bias
i think people are scared to make
predictions based on how they feel
because they're scared of being wrong
i don't care i'll tell you i feel i
think trump's gonna win um i'm not
entirely sure about the senate or the
house
um i could be wrong i don't know for
sure i just have a feeling
based on the tightening of the polls and
the voter registration gap that looked
really good for trump and republicans
we'll see how it plays out i think
there's going to be a wave a massive
wave of violence
particularly from the left i believe
that may coax out a right-wing response
of some sort
not entirely sure but i i talk to a lot
of people and they're like
i don't think so and i'm like a guy
walked up to some trump support and put
two bolts in his chest right
and then antivir cheered for it a
security guard in denver shot a trump
supporter in the face and then they
cheered for it right
like the stuff isn't slowing down it's
speeding up exactly and so how and i
think what i struggle with is
i don't know a way where it slows down
exactly and so at some point you got to
assume that it bubbles over and you're
right i think it's i think it's very
very difficult for americans who you
know
none of us have been alive for 150 years
we've never really seen anything like
this and so
one of the models that i think is more
helpful to look at rather than like a
u.s civil war or what have you is
something like the troubles in ireland
where you have you have two different
sort of factions of people
who um like it gets more and more
intense and more and more frustrated and
at some point people start shooting
have you have you ever uh been to
belfast yeah have you
you've seen the peace wall yeah you did
you look at the weird graffiti on each
side of it so this is really interesting
for people who aren't familiar
so this is uh do you want to explain the
troubles a little bit yeah so um in
in ireland there there was a tenuous
relationship between the irish
uh and the english for a long time
dating back to the first british
occupation was in what like 1099
something like that
way in the early odds and so eventually
after years and years of strife
the centuries of strife uh it hit a
boiling point when
what is now ireland the republic of
ireland seceded
um from from what was then england
what's now the uk
to become their own sovereign country um
and then we were left with northern
ireland which had
uh about a 50-50 split i think at the
time of catholics and protestants there
was a lot of sectarian frustration and
that kind of the spill over violence and
then eventually it all came to a head
and so people started shooting and you
would have bombings yeah
exactly there were bombings uh there
were shootings there there was a
the ira the irish republican army who
was a faction of people in ireland who
thought that by causing violence
particularly in northern ireland and in
london that they could get the rest of
northern ireland free they you get the
english shop
so the peace wall separated the i i
came wrong two communities right it was
like you know the i don't i don't wanna
i don't know the names of them but
basically i went to belfast and i was
there for that big
bonfire night they do where they set up
those that's that's crazy it's like
30 feet tall of just pallets and wood
and they torch the whole thing and
man it lights up this guy like the sun
anyway
the peace wall is interesting because on
one side it's very
imperial militaristic and on the other
side it's very
sjw left wing very stereotypically
culture war
and i was asking this dude there about
it i'm like on one side it's
you know pro-palestine on the other side
is pro-israel what does that have to do
with ireland it doesn't matter
he told me if one side says it the other
side says the opposite
right and now what does that sound like
today with trump yeah trump says it
they say the opposite that's just the
way it rolls so
yeah and it only goes once right and so
what ended up what ended up happening
there's
the good friday peace accords i after
after years of bloodshed right serious
bloodshed
eventually they they signed a peace
treaty but it's because the the fire had
kind of burned itself out and my worry
is we're at a point where we've got a
lot of embers and the embers keep
kicking up and they keep getting hotter
and they keep getting hotter
and there's no one sitting around to
throw water on the situation that we
have now
and so until those embers kick up into
something like a fire and then that fire
burns itself out
i don't know how else we walk about
we're a much bigger cr country
yeah in ireland and a lot more guns and
that was northern ireland
we're talking about the entirety of the
country so
my concern is that initially when we
started seeing culture war conflict
street battles
a lot of people were like oh it's not
gonna get any you know i had people
telling me when i said this is gonna get
worse they're like no
because the government will never allow
it they're in government
what happens when you have someone in
one branch of the government who's on
one side of the debate
and a person in the same department is
on the other side and they start butting
heads with each other
about who's evil who's not what happens
when you start seeing like we're seeing
now in like the pacific northwest these
racially segregated trainings they're
doing
yeah at a certain point someone's gonna
be like i refuse i'll tell you what
really scares me
when uh you know the the trans children
issue
yeah joe biden was asked a question
about i think an eight-year-old trans
child i'm not here to make a judgment
call or moral call i'm gonna i'm
because i don't want to in flame
tensions worse than they are but i tell
you this
you have a fight happening in texas i
don't know what the latest development
is where the mother says the child is
trans and the dad says the child is not
right i am worried to think about what's
going to happen when one parent feels
their child
is being physically harmed and they have
no choice but to engage in some kind of
physically you know physical maneuver of
some kind of something right
whether you're left or right and how
many and i think i think that's a really
good microcosm but think about how many
other situations in american life that
could lead to something like that right
like
there's i part of my concern is there's
so many little fires going all at once
that i think individually could each be
problematic but when they all come
together right when you have a bunch of
different reasons why a bunch of
different people
are mad and there's two sides to to
whatever the argument is you've got two
camps you've got two teams
that it is combustible right and you
have all these individual interpersonal
circumstances that are combustible sit
against a backdrop that is already
incredibly combustible
and and yeah so i mean whether it's
whether it's parents fighting over a
custody battle like that with a child
who may or may not be trans who's i
don't know eight years old
or a situation with a street rally in
portland when you have that many sources
of tension
eventually one of them is going to
bubble up and i worry that there's a
little bit of a contagion going on
for something like that where as soon as
people get angry and start shooting more
people get angry and start shooting yeah
absolutely after 9 11 everybody came out
i was in new york city
that day actually um i lived there and
everyone came out of their houses and
was like
sitting together on the street and
talking and there's a lot of humanity
and it was this tragedy that bound us
and i think that
there's going to be a false flag tragedy
coming up i think i would imagine that
they've been trying it russia's one
was they what do you mean that the us
government will impose some sort of
some sort of collective tragedy on us so
that we don't go to
civil war who's the government though
trump's fighting the government the
government's
i don't know who runs the show exactly
no there's nobody there's the trump
state there's the
yeah the intelligence agencies are
fractured i think screaming there will
be many different people trying to
trying to show us many maybe it'll be
aliens but it won't really cover you
didn't do it just be
vigilant about the next unifying tragedy
because it'll probably
let's look through it instead of at it
um
if what you're saying is true it'd be a
great thing for this country to kill the
wounds
we should we should do it we don't need
a fake
tragedy to bind us kovit didn't do it
man
i worry that we don't even have unifying
tragedies anymore we don't well it could
be like a
weather tragedy so i think we should
decentralize our power grid first of all
and then if we have a tsunami like we
have three hurricanes in one season last
year
we have bunch of hurricanes recently yes
that's terrifying so
if we're getting flooding and then
there's a a
volcano explodes and then there's a 10
10 year long winter or it's not gonna do
ten month long winter
i mean that was i'll tell you what's
gonna happen will support each other no
they won't that could help
in california when the drought hit the
cities voted to take the water away from
the poor migrants in two seconds
in two seconds it was gone and their
wells ran dry
and then non-profits had to intervene
and give them non-potable water that's a
lot of us because of the central
electric grid for profit we all had
electricity
water with electricity the listen
through condensation now now they're
talking about they want to divert
fresh water from the from the delta from
from the bay area
south to help the farmers which would
which could potentially cause
uh the water pressure to invert so
salt water would pour in to the to the
bay area
turning all of the water brackish and
just mutilating all the farms
people are fighting over water these re
they're not gonna come together in a
natural disaster
when people have a fundamental tribalist
view and the only thing that matters is
my tribe versus your tribe
the earth could explode and they would
be like it's your fault yeah but my
i guess technology and can help us in a
time of crisis because if we could
if we all had electricity and we could
all condense our water from the air
then if there was a flood or something
we could share water and not have fear
of not having enough i'll tell you what
where we are now it's like
like 10 gallons of water and
condensation every morning on the deck
it's
like you walk outside and you're
splashing i'm like man i'd like to get a
funnel just yeah dude there's a lot of
water out in the air
that you can make in in california there
wasn't
and it was funny when i saw the canals
full of fresh water
and i asked the farmer why they weren't
just using that he said the city's voted
we can't touch it
that's how los angeles got made they
diverted water down that's that's what
they're doing right now the river
river valley i think it was el holland
uh
listen la's got a ton of people and they
say we get the water you don't
and so it becomes a bat it becomes an
issue of power they didn't care about
the poor migrants who were dying of
thirst
they said give me your water shut your
your mouth yeah getting
not getting enough water for people
could be a good start a disaster won't
bring us together a disaster right now
in my opinion would scare people
and cause them to go nuts right now yeah
because we're not prepared for it no
they'll go in the other direction they
would say gimme gimme gimme fu
i need to survive yeah yeah like to me i
feel like it would be like
if hurricane katrina happened everywhere
in the country all at once right and so
unfortunately tim i think you're right i
think that we're at a point now where we
you have two camps of people
who have really really struggled not
only to see their own
like their own fellows as patriots or
compatriots
they struggle to see them as human right
and so i think it's a lot easier
one i think it makes things like someone
from antifa shooting a trump supporter
more likely to happen one
two even in the more the more mundane
the more milk toast variety
i think it makes it easier to believe
someone like rudy giolani would do
something like whatever it is
right and so it makes it i think it just
makes all of us a lot more willing to
believe
things that we wouldn't believe one
about someone we know two about someone
who we think shares our worldview or
three like
at least someone who we can assume is
going to be acting in good faith and so
where we are now is
the reason you get these media cycles
whether it's russian disinformation or
whatever
else the reason they pick up so quickly
is we're all like we're all pointing our
mental guns at one another anyway
and when you're and i think when you're
doing that all you need like all you
need is the tiniest little semblance of
a match
to be able to kick things off and kick
them off badly and it seems like every
morning we wake up
to do that anew it's a new new cycle
let's do something i swear to god this
is a video game or some sort of
simulation and we are controlling the
morale it's a morale thing because if
people are psycho
they're going to kill each other but if
they're not if they love each other
they're going to help each other but
this has been a part of human life
and human existence with the internet
video where definitely yeah the
internet's making everything worse
we're better it just depends i don't i
don't know that we spend enough time
talking about the second of their lower
consequences of social media and the
internet and other things like that
because you're right i mean i think
one of my big contentions with the media
is that the thing that they are doing
that tends to be bad is they're
responding to a certain set of
incentives that aren't that their their
readers are not well served by
if a media needs to make money by
serving ads they need eyeballs
they need eyeballs they're not going to
publish things that matter they're going
to publish things that collect eyeballs
right and as a result of that you have
all of these twisted incentive systems
that i think are
they're too big and they're too scary
and they're too colossal for any of us
to try and talk about and wrestle with
because this is a system that we all
live within and the idea of trying to to
break out or punch out of that thing is
scary and frightening but i think if we
invested a little bit more time and
energy
talking about those sorts of things it
would probably be beneficial i think
you're right
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification
bell and we are also available on all
podcast platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time
you